this week on the NewsHour we've been
focusing on the scourge of knife crime
across the country stabbings have
sharply increased and in the capital
they have reached an all-time high
tonight an exclusive interview with
football manager turned much-loved
TV celebrity Harry Redknapp who's been
so shocked by the scale of knife crime
he's throwing his weight behind a
campaign to tackle the escalating
violence on Britain's streets the
campaign is run by Mark Prince the
father a promising young footballer at
one of Harry's former clubs Queens Park
Rangers who was stabbed in the heart and
killed while trying to break up a fight
outside his North London school if he'd
lived Cayenne Prince would today be 28
and likely at the top of his footballing
career I'm joined now by Harry Redknapp
and Kyon's father mark and Mark I think
we start with you just remind us exactly
what happened to your son my son was
stabbed outside his school made a six
Wow 2006 made 18th outside where Academy
trying to break up a fight stabbed down
inside in front of hundreds of school
kids and since then you've been
campaigning you've been spending your
life campaigning to tackle knife crime
driven focused we've got to save more
young lives we've got to stop parents
from this grieving we've got change
mindsets of young people that's the
focus and Harry you're getting involved
now is that because you've been so
shocked by the scale of what's happening
on our streets
yeah be up I first met mark at the
spirit of London awards many years ago
and I was just really taken out what an
amazing man he was you know and how he'd
willing to dedicate his life to trying
to help fight knife crime everyone lost
his own boy at such tragic circumstances
so this was the way before sort of the
recent you know me going and doing
whatever I did in the jungle east we've
been talking about this for a long time
and so it was always a case of I'm here
to help mark in any small way I can I'm
gonna be available for him if he needs
me because what he does is the main he
does what he's done is
amazing and I would just you know want
to dedicate my time and uh if I can to
help him in any small way we've got to
do something about it mark you know
every day we pick up the paper
there's innocent kids as kids were
getting stabbed it's just it's just an
epidemic they're epidemic at a moment
that we need to do something about you
know and you're prepared are you to go
into young offenders institutions
juvenile prisons with mark schools to
talk about this what yeah what would you
say to these young people what we've got
to do with you it's mark would explain
it sure much greater it's it's not the
thing you do I carry a knife you know I
know they probably say mark it's to
protect their cells because other kids
carry knives but there's got to be a way
that we've got to stop everybody
carrying knives you know see the way I
look at this is why outlaw reason why I
love this mix with me and Harry is
because how many represents a different
demographic influential people somebody
who has worked from the bottom up so he
has certain privileges now he has an
influence and he's able to come into a
room and what somebody else couldn't do
when they walk into a room how he could
do he could get the attention he's got
respect from Ages all the way from his
age all the way down to young people
he's just captured a new audience with
the jungle and everything is gone
through so a young audience knows finds
him real funny just for luck and even
like a grandad figure yeah they were
they can relate to but Harry why has it
affected you like it like it clearly has
what I just think well we when I first
met mark i sat down with a group
appearance at night who had all lost
kiddies it wasn't just mark there was a
whole group and listening to their
stories it was just an incredible it was
the most touching thing I think you know
I sat there and listened to all these
lovely parents who had great kids who
suddenly all got you know became victims
of knife crime so I felt at that time
you know I said to my I would love to if
ever you need me mark I'm always gonna
be you know I'd love to get involved
with you and help in any way I can and
we're seeing we're just seeing I should
say pictures from that awful day in May
2006 when Cayenne was stabbed and hairy
Cayenne would now be
young earlier what 2728 possibly at the
top of a Premier League career you may
have managed him you everybody I'm a
really QPR spoke so highly of him a city
what a fantastic young talent he was you
know great young football we're in a
great young man and Mark you know how do
you approach this problem I mean what is
it getting to these children when
they're really young what are you
dealing with you get it there's
preventive measures you know is you
gotta have intervention program set up
but you gotta eat the heart of young
people young people want to have you
engaged in and understanding where
they're coming from so we're making this
all what are the solutions to knife
crime so we can't we can't change how to
police or tackle in communities and is
that distrust you know and as a police
to take responsibility can't take
responsibility for the government
ignoring it and kind of doing things
that sort of create this situation as
well with with with with low funding and
and taking away opportunities for young
people so so if we haven't been able to
tackle that let's tackle what we can do
for young people personally within the
community which is reaching out for them
creating opportunities for them for them
to be able to thrive changing that
mindset because it's all about the think
think you when you empower young people
you get them to understand that they
need self belief because it was self
belief that changed my life I was just
one of them kids on the street homeless
at fifteen wasn't going anywhere I got
involved in a wrong company doing the
wrong things to make revenue and then I
began to change and believe that way I
haven't even tried another way why
haven't I tried another way well I mean
I've given myself an opportunity and
look what I achieved
becoming number one in the country
becoming number one in the world for
making an effort yeah as a boxer I
should say yeah can you imagine what it
is like for these parents that are
hearing that their son has been stabbed
to death
no he's a countless parents now yes love
it when you sit down and listen to the
stories it's heart-wrenching
you just cannot you know the kids go out
there waiting for the killer to arrive
home so they get a message it they've no
longer got a son or a daughter or
whatever
happening right across the board isn't
it it might it isn't a render sand
something it's got to be done we every
day we pick up the paper now and there's
another kid getting stabbed and I'll
tell you how powerful Harry is somebody
like this coming forward 72 year old man
there's loads of people that say now
what can we do how he sets forward and
says well I'll do whatever I can do so
so Harry has connections how he has got
opportunities for young people so when
we develop them change their mindset and
we search this young person look we've
developed you've change this mindset
you're good at football
here's we can be able to give you an
opening to go for a trial or do
something and we got somebody on board
that can help to give a young person
opportunity yeah so you walk into a
young offenders institution you walk
into a school or a social club what do
you say to these kids who think who may
be members of gangs where they say well
we have to carry knives but it's not the
way to lead your life mark you know and
I think mark would like to get them into
into boxing you know it would you've
only got a readers greatest fighter
Anthony Joshua admits he could have been
going on the wrong road if he hadn't of
you know got into the boxing and what a
great role model is now and I'm sure
there's loads of kids out there that we
can you can turn their heads and get
them to understand there is another way
in life carrying knives is that is not
is not what the piece of evidence so how
are you so evidence of what can be done
as a 72 year old man and taking the
right choice he's making the right paths
in life and saying I'm here I might not
be your agent might not be able to
understand how you think right now on
the streets but I'm here to help create
an opportunity I'm here to encourage you
that's why I've taken my time out to be
here that speaks volumes to young people
that Harry would do that and many other
kid got the people out there and I'm not
calling a neighbor there's loads of
people that can step forward and there
are current with young people that isn't
offering their self to the kind of so
Harry yeah so Harry I mean what shocked
me are the statistics about twenty
percent of the children being
round with knives or aged between 10 and
17 I mean it's starting so young what do
you make of you know those statistics
yeah I mean they carry and you'll be
seeing a young boy of 14 get killed just
a few weeks there and we you know yeah
except in its schools I mean but you
know as Mark said you know crime is 15
years 15 years of age at school fire
side to school that's why going into
school the so important into schools and
as Spira a future champions campaign is
so important and just having Harry's
present sale means a lot to the young
people because they know his pedigree
and who he's been around the footballers
and his level of management his
knowledge and skills
it's like Alex Ferguson I saw him doing
a little film clip I watched with him in
front of young people that were trying
to build their self up the impact that
he has on them as they look at his
maturity and his experience is the same
impact Harry's gonna have on these young
people who want to aspire to become
somebody and will sport play a role in
this you will be here yeah I mean if we
can open
help these I'm sure there's loads of
these kids out there who were taking the
wrong road take the right Road you look
at a lot of today's young footballers
I'm sure they're Bennett let cross a lot
of fewer muda being around mates I was
over boy yesterday who was a good who's
been a good players just finished his
career but he told me growing up he
Nottingham he had friends who his best
pals ended up in in taking the wrong
path and he was lucky that he managed to
football saved him basically and there's
loads of kids out there like that mark
you know boxing football kinds of sport
that can make a change make a difference
their lives
gonna do your bit that's what we're
gonna do we're gonna try I'll try
whatever I can tell it Prince of Peace
because it's a book full of the pain of
what you've gone through in life pull of
gripping through life to get to a point
where you can come out the mess of the
streets and become someone by using
sports and boxing alright well look mark
thanks very much indeed
good luck the campaign and Harry thank
you for you amazing man yeah well thank
you for coming in appreciate it